ところで、河野さんはリスクだとか安全の問題を
議論する際にしばしば発せられる問いなんですけれども、
How safe is safe enough?と、こういうフレーズ、
どっかで聞いたことありますでしょうか。
どの程度安全であれば十分に安全だといえるのか、
と考えられるのかっていう問いですよね。
でも、簡単には答えの出ない問いなんだろうな
というふうには思いますね（？）。
そうなんですね。この原子力の
安全性の問題でありますとか、あるいは最近、
わが国では原子力発電所の再稼働の問題などが
注目されておりますけれども、こういった
この主の問いがまさしくこの
How safe is safe enough?という問いですね。
こういう問いには科学あるいは
技術だけで答え出せるでしょうか。
それは難しいでしょうね。
そうですよね。原子力の分野で非常に大きな仕事を
なさったアルビン・ワインバーグという先生が
いらっしゃいますけど、もうかなり古い方ですけども。
彼はこのような問題のことを
トランスサイエンスの領域に属する問題であると、
こういうふうに呼んだわけです。
科学的な合理性によって説明可能な
専門的に閉じた領域と、価値や権力っていうのを
基準として行われる政治的な領域というのが
重なり合っている部分で科学によって
問うことができるけれども、
科学によって答えることのできないような問題群。
それから成る領域っていうふうに定義されている。
そうですね。そのとおりですね。
今、挙げていただいた例は、すべて
トランスサイエンスの問題を含んでいると、
こういうふうに思います。受講生の皆さんも、ぜひ
具体的な例というのを考えていただきたいと思います。
ともかく、技術が社会に本当の意味で
受け入れられるためには、その技術が持つ
リスクに関して社会的な合意っていうのが
必要になってくるわけですけれども、
そのためには技術に携わる技術者が本来、
専門の技術の世界だけの能力だけではなくて、
常に自分が従事しているその技術について
一般の人々がどのように認識をして判断をしているのか。
これを問い続けていく必要があると思います。
それにきちんとした社会的な
合意形成のプロセスを踏んでいれば、技術者は
自分の仕事に自信ややりがいを持てるでしょうし、
胸を張って技術の仕事ができるんじゃないか
というふうに思います。そうすることによって、
社会に貢献しているということを
実感できるわけですから、既に議論したように、
技術者自身のwell-beingというのを、
よく生きていることっていうのも
高まっていくというふうに考えられます。
さて、科学技術と社会の関係に意識的（？）であって
高い関心を持っている、そういう一般の人々、
市民の人たちに対して、技術の専門家である技術者は
どのように対応していくべきなんでしょうか。
科学技術の成果が社会に対して
これだけ広くて大きくて複雑なかたちで
影響を与えている以上、技術者は専門家としても
トランスサイエンスの領域にも関与して
社会的な合意形成あるいは
インフォームドコンセントを確立すること、
これを目指して自分の専門に閉じこもらずに
専門外のことにも、より社会的なことにも
直接的に関与していくべきだとこういうふうに考えます。
この責任を全うすることによって、
リスクをはらんだ技術を扱う専門家の倫理、
それが専門家の倫理として求められていることなんだと、
こういうふうに考えられます。
日本学術会議は東日本大震災のあとに
科学者や技術者ってのが十分役割を
果たせなかったっていう反省のもとで2013年に
科学者の行動規範というのを改訂しましたよね。
おっしゃるとおりです。本当に当時、専門家の人たちが
いろんな意見を出して一般の人たちが
混乱をしてしまったというようなこともございましたし、
そこで大きな反省があったわけですけども、
改訂の際に加えられた条文には、
次のようなものがあります。河野さん、
ちょっと確認のために読んでいただけますかね。
わかりました。1番目としてですけれども、
科学者は、社会と科学者コミュニティとの
よりよい相互理解のために、市民との対話と交流に
積極的に参加をする。また、社会のさまざまな
課題の解決と福祉の実現を図るために、政策立案、
決定者に対して政策形成に有効な科学的助言の
提供に努める。その際、科学者の合意に基づく
助言を目指し、意見の相違が存在するときは、
これをわかりやすく解説すると。
さらに続けてですけれども、
科学者は公共の福祉に資することを目的として
研究活動を行い、客観的で科学的な根拠に基づく
公正な助言を行う。その際、科学者の発言が
世論及び政策形成に対して与える影響の重大さと
責任を自覚し、権威を乱用しない。
また、科学的助言の質の確保に最大限努め、
同時に科学的知見にかかる不確実性及び
見解の多様性について明確に説明すると。
先生も強調されていらっしゃいましたけれども、
日本学術会議の定義では、科学者というのは
新しい知識を作り出したり、それを利用
あるいは活用する専門家ですから、
当然技術者というのも含まれるわけですよね。
そうですね。ですから、ここで言われてることは
技術者にも当てはまるということでありますけれども、
この条文っていうのは、先ほど申し上げましたけれども、
東日本大震災のあとに技術者を含む多くの専門家が
専門家としての役割を果たせなかったと。
そういうところから得られた教訓でありますので
大変重要だと思います。さて、
この原子力発電所の事故の、先ほど、
いろんな調査委員会ができたと言いましたけれども、
別の政府の調査委員会の委員長であった
畑村洋太郎先生がいらっしゃいますけども、
この先生が報告書の一番最後で教訓として
次のようなことをまとめていらっしゃいます。
まず一つは、あり得ることは起こると。
あり得ないと思うことも起こるんだと。
見たくないものは見えない。見たいものが見えると。
可能な限りの想定と十分な準備をすることが
必要であると。かたちを作っただけでは
機能しないんだと。仕組みは作れるけれども、
目的は共有されないんだと。すべて変わるものであって、
変化に柔軟に対応しなければならないと。
危険の存在っていうのを認めて、危険に正対して
議論できる、そういう文化を作んなきゃいけないんだ。
次が非常に重要だと思いますけれども、
自分の目で見て自分の頭で考え、
判断、行動することが重要である。
こういうことを認識して、そのような能力を
涵養することが重要であると。
こういうふうに言ってらっしゃるわけですね。
特に技術者倫理の観点から言えば、
最後のポイントってすごい重要だということですね。
自分の目で見て自分の頭で考えて、
判断、行動する能力こそが倫理的な
行動設定能力であるわけですし、
新しい時代の技術者に求められているような
能力であると＊＊＊ですね。
この東日本大震災は歴史的な大地震、
それに伴う想定をはるかに超えた巨大な津波、
さらに考える必要がないとされていた全電源喪失。
そういった、あと、原子力関係者の人たちの
慢心による人災であったと、そういったものが
複合された大災害であったわけですけども、
この大災害は人間社会と科学技術の在り方を
大きく変えて、何度も言っておりますけれども、
新しい時代というのをもたらしました。
私は、この新しい時代の特徴っていうのを
次のようにまとめることができると思っています。
まず、この新しい時代においては、
科学技術の成果への、それまでの妄信的な依存、
こういうものから脱却する必要があるでしょうと。
さらに、科学技術が人間社会に与える影響、
それを俯瞰的な視点から見る必要が
出てきているでしょうと。それと、それまでの、
旧来の経済的あるいは物質的な豊かさから
心の豊かさへという、これをさらに転換を
進めていく必要があると。さらに、
この講義の中でも議論してまいりましたけれども、
人間にとっての幸せ、well-being、
これを科学的に考察をして、それを高めるんだという
方向への転換ということも必要だと思います。
既に検討しましたように、この発電所での事故から
われわれは多くの教訓を得たわけです。
公衆の安全を最優先するためには
規制のとりこを脱却しなければならないわけですし、
そのためには時の政府や自分が所属する組織の指示に
盲目的に従うのではなくて、自分の目で見て
自分の頭で考えて判断、行動する力。
すなわち技術者倫理の能力が重要なのだということを
さらにもう一度繰り返しておきたいと思います。
新しい時代の技術者というのは、この教訓を
意思決定と行動に反映させなければいけないわけですね。